it's not how we're supposed to be it
should have been a packed Hall with lots
of friends and a celebration of 4 years
of high school instead it's graduation
marked with a socially distance dance
with a family in a driveway you know
that when we are able to reunite I see
with my friends that it's going to be a
bittersweet moment and we're going to
you know hug it out maybe if we're
allowed to me is graduation season in
America's High School's big celebrations
ceremonies and excitement the moment to
move on to something new University or a
career for the class of 2020 those
moments and memories have been stolen
away nobody wants to go to school it
sucks it's boring but the end of your
senior year you get to do all of these
incredible things you've been working
towards and you get the payoff and now I
don't get that clear Rodgers moved to
the u.s. two years ago from the UK where
they do things differently graduation
ceremonies are not common I'd grown up
watching that sort of thing in the
movies and I was like wow I actually get
to experience that so that sort of was
quite upsetting Jai Coronado was ready
to leave high school she's been accepted
to university to pursue a career in
nursing and watching how her world has
changed in just a matter of weeks
watching how people have relied on
health professionals makes her even more
determined that's where her future lies
I wish I could be helping everyone right
now and it's kind of sad that I can't
but that's what's also motivating me to
still be a nurse in case this comes back
not everyone leaving high school has the
same certainty and it is a real knock-on
effect colleges and universities across
America say they're expecting to lose 20
percent of the students who have already
enrolled many simply won't be able to
afford it anymore
and it's not just a one-year thing one
in 10 say they're already making other
plans what we do often help students in
the last year of high school plan for
the future a future no laced with
uncertainty my biggest fear is that kids
that were on the edge in that I would
have been able to do more for are still
gonna
make a decision on what their
post-secondary plans are and leave high
school on June 16 not knowing what to do
on June 17 schools are doing what they
can to celebrate graduation virtual
ceremonies pushing events back several
weeks it won't be the same but then
neither is the world the students are
about to enter Alan Fisher al Jazeera
Arlington Virginia